you know at this point the movie I'm
really irritated at is Batman bad blood
because it was good and if it hadn't
been I could have safely written off
this entire DC animated continuity thing
a long time ago Teen Titans Judas
contract I have been putting this off
for a while and that's with good reason
and that is I don't like the vast
majority of the newer DC animated films
and I almost universally don't like the
ones that are in the maintained
continuity the only ones that have
worked for me at all were dark justice
and the aforementioned Batman bad blood
dark justice was disconnected enough I
could you could almost call it its own
thing and bad blood basically lucked out
by taking the things that I had major
problems with in shuffling them off
elsewhere so I did not come into this
with a lot of hope because Justice
League vs Teen Titans was the standard
kind of awful that these things have
been and this is not that bad but it
ain't good now I I will say the the main
thing that had me dreading this is
thankfully not in the movie as much as I
was afraid of and that's Damian Wayne I
really really really really really
really really really really hate Damian
Wayne I've hated him since his first now
I get I'm talking about the animated
version I'm not even don't don't tell me
he's better in the comics I don't care I
watched these I deal with him in this
and he is insufferable in this he's so
bad and he's he is just as bad now as
he's always been he's the same
self-entitled pompous little prick he's
just not center stage this time so I
would say that helps except that they've
unloaded angst onto all the other
characters as well like every
is bathed in angst so Damien's still got
a ton of angst Jaime Reyes is Blue
Beetle has got a whole bunch of angst in
they give him this whole subplot with
his family Raven what she lives in angst
Ville so they I mean that's just normal
for her
we've got Tara broad and she's got a
whole bunch of banks that gets explained
later on so okay maybe they justify and
look I get I get
teenage superheroes teenagers deal with
thanks but when you give almost the
entire cast angst it you give me nobody
latch on to last time I was last time
they brought in the Teen Titans for this
I was able to latch on a little bit to
Beast Boy and I can't even do that here
on this one because they've made him
borderline stalker assault II towards
Tara there's two major reasons that that
this does not work this whole his
attraction to Tara thing and one of
these two things needed to be in better
balance either he needed to be less
aggressive and be more just kind of
pining for her as opposed to getting in
her face and literally demanding a kiss
or she needed to be more coy and her
rejections cuz she is very flat out no
room for interpretation she does not
like you dude get out of her face and
between the two of those being at the
level that they are I now really don't
like Beast Boy in this because it's like
dude leave her alone
you're a creep at this point coming into
this review I thought I wasn't gonna do
spoilers but I think I'm gonna do
spoilers because you know what this
movie and it'll save you the trouble of
having to watch it because on top of
everything else while the the things
that are bad about this art as bad or as
prevalent as have been in the worst of
these things this was boring and that's
kind of new even if they're worse these
things usually aren't boring and this
one kind of is the main reason for the
boredom is the stakes don't work the big
bad and this one is brother
and his whole plan is to capture the
Teen Titans and drain them of their
powers and suck it into himself that's
his big scheme now obviously that's a
bad thing he can do a lot of damage if
he had their powers etc etc but there's
there's no immediate sense of the
collateral damage we don't have any firm
idea of exactly what he will do once he
has his powers I mean we know he's a bad
dude he will do stuff that is not good
but there isn't a firm sense of stakes
there therefore the only stakes we have
is the endangerment of the Titans
themselves and unfortunately like I said
I don't like them I ain't like even the
ones that I kind of like previously are
grading on me here so when the only
stakes is the lives of the heroes and I
don't really like the heroes guess what
it doesn't work my set brother blood was
the big bad really though he he gets
introduced at the beginning shows up
again for a boss fight at the end but in
the middle is all Deathstroke and
Deathstroke is one of the few things
that is decent is pretty good it's
helped greatly by the fact that they
were replaced the voice actor who voiced
him back and son of Batman because that
guy was terrible they had a new voice
actor and who does the character much
much better and he actually kind of
works he's one of the stronger aspects
since I'm on the semi praise train
Nightwing worked pretty good he's got a
good level of charm I actually I uh uh
uh huh
this felt like a nasty rug pulled
because the the film starts in flashback
with the arrival of Starfire and the
older version of the Teen Titans and you
know Robin is there but it's Dick
Grayson and I didn't realize that right
off so I'm watching going hey ah this
you know Robin he's a little older he's
but he's working for me here cool and
then it flashes forward and Robin that
brought us now Nightwing and there's
Damion Wade be exactly as I remember my
god damn it
so there's all that honestly though I
don't know why it starts with that
flashback because it shows how Starfire
first came onto the team except that has
no relevance whatsoever to the plot
Starfire's background and her history
don't come into play at all
not even a little and also the showed
skeeves on her a little bit cuz she
falls out of the sky the first thing she
does once the monsters that followed her
adult with is kiss Dick Grayson cuz
apparently that's how she learns
language I don't know if they made that
up or pulled it from the comic I don't
care it's stupid and then what as soon
as she after she gives him she gets off
him and walks away and the camera
lingers on her ass like annoyingly long
and I don't know how old she's supposed
to be at that point in that flashback
later on when we see her it's pretty
clear she's an adult but in that
flashback I'm like I'll hold this
character is supposed to be and speaking
of that Tara I like I said I will spoil
crap so Tara is she's the Judas cuz she
betrays the Titans to Deathstroke and
part of that thing is Deathstroke saved
her when she was younger so she's got a
really big crush on him and she was she
wants tuck yeah she wants to get right
to it and he's been putting her off
saying you know we can let let's finish
what we're in you've been a deep-cover
listed then you know we'll do that stuff
you want to do I didn't catch at any
point in the movie that it established
how old Tara was so when she shows up
with really overdone makeup in a
negligee and drapes herself all over a
Deathstroke yeah I was not comfortable
with that sorry and oh god what else is
there to even say and then there's just
a whole crap ton of tiny little stupid
things like what why does brother Bloods
base start to collapse after he dies why
like there's no reason it's just it's
just it's just video game logic boss is
dead now he must escape cuz it's
crumbling and then Tara dies as a guy
and I get that she's destroying
everything but it's like her entire
power set is moving earth and she can
make earth even stay in the air and she
gets crushed and buried under rocks
really I mean the one thing I'll say is
okay props to them for having the balls
to actually kill her except that that
only would have had some meaning if she
hadn't shown up for the first time in
this movie and that's sort of the other
thing like if there was a character that
we were going to get extra time with at
the front end it shouldn't have been
Starfire it should have been Tara
because we only get this movie to get
invested with her and that's hard to do
because she's despite it being in deep
cover and with the group she is
completely standoffish to them from the
get-go so already I'm like oh she's not
well integrated into the group and she
doesn't have a proper arc in terms of
getting a sense of redemption because
she doesn't choose to side with the
Titans she just gets betrayed by
Deathstroke so the guy that she betrayed
these people for then betrays her she
didn't learn a lesson she'd make a
choice she didn't grow she just got
screwed over by somebody worse than her
yet it's played like it's supposed to be
tragic and yes they gave her a tragic
backstory everything but it's so
artificial and unearned and might have
worked if she if this hadn't been her
first movie then the betrayal might have
actually hit and her death might have
hit but it doesn't oh you know what
randomly one more random thing that I
genuinely loved I thought was great
because we get it's not really a montage
but we get kind of a clever thing where
Nightwing goes to where all the Titans
should be and finds basically scenes of
minor destruction of what happened and
he pieces together what happened to them
how each of them got captured and that
in himself kind of clever not bad but
Beast Boy how they captured Beast Boy
was basically they tricked him into a
room where there was a button that says
do
press this button Eddy press that button
and tranquilizer tarts shot him yeah
that was kind of that was kind of
awesome and hilarious and I love that
moment but then that's the one moment I
was loved unequivocally love that moment
that was great that's the only thing
that was great there's a handful of
other things that are okay the actions
alright it's fine Nightwing's finds
Starfire after the awning of her but was
fine but the rest of them you know they
turn Beast Boy into a creeper and they
they didn't get that there are ways to
do that where it comes off as endearing
it didn't with him it really came off
like she wants him to leave her alone
and he won't which I'm sorry that's not
endearing and so he didn't work
hi Mae there was nothing wrong with
Jaime but loading him with angst when
that didn't even really have a proper
payoff meant he was just one more layer
of angst that didn't need to be there
Raven basically does nothing Tara gets
focused but like I said she hasn't they
they didn't do the foundational work to
have the stuff that they do with her
actually land and pay off the way that
it needs to this thing yeah this just is
this this was about as painful as I
figured it was gonna be so yeah that's
that's Teen Titans the Judas contract
why do I keep watching these things so
those are my thoughts have you seen this
if you have what did you think about it
or what are your thoughts on the DC
Animated universe the current state of
it as it were whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast I am also one
half of the punch like a girl podcast
available on the fire and water Network
starting on October and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]